jacquat bouchard en afghanistan dans
votre affaire il s'est passé
pratiquement la même chose avait été
retenue en otage en afghanistan par le
gouvernement afghan
et là encore on a utilisé les médias oui
on a utilisé les médias et j'ai joué mon
propre rôle si vous voulez parce que
dans cette une partie comme dans une
pièce de théâtre où chacun doit
connaître sa réplique
alors de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit pour
les spécialistes de ce genre d'opération
dans mon cas précis à kaboul il
s'agissait pour eux de me de mehdi b et
de me faire dire un certain nombre de
choses
j'avais mon rôle à jouer et il fallait
qu'il n'y ait pas de dérapage dans mon
texte
il ya eu des dérapages bien mais qui
n'ont pas présenté des conséquences
tragiques mais dans le cas d d d otages
américains qui sont eux dans les mains
entre les mains de terroristes
cela peut être beaucoup plus grave mais
vous aussi vous avez tenu une conférence
de presse j'ai tenu une conférence de
presse effectivement est théoriquement
cette conférence de presse a donné lieu
à même une répétition
enfin on me disait qu est ce que vous
allez dire si on vous pose telle
question et je pense que pour les otages
c'est un petit peu la même chose
non mais ce que ce que vous avez raison
de souligner c'est que dans tout ça il
ya actuellement une mise en scène à
laquelle nous participons les les
pirates de beyrouth ont monté
l'opération est absolument comme une
opération comme une opération de
marketing
il s'inspire des méthodes des
spécialistes de la publicité par exemple
ils utilisent les otages comme un
véritable levier de pression sur les
dirigeants américains sur le président
nixon sur le président régal le
responsable des otages comme le pilote
l'autre jour en appelle au président
reagan pour ne pas qu'ils commettent
l'irréparable c'est à dire qu'ils soient
tentés par une opération militaire
ces salles vous avez eu l'impression
d'être utilisés vous aussi dans votre
affaire pour réclamer quelque chose à
l'occident oui il ya même à mon corps
défendant peut-être je n'étais pas
vraiment conscient mais mais j'ai été
certainement utiliser alors évidemment
il ya notre responsabilité alors
justement on peut se poser la question
de notre responsabilité de la
responsabilité de la télévision est ce
qu'on doit montrer ces images toujours
est-ce qu'on doit entrer nous dans le
jeu
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas complices
en fait c'est ça le problème les images
du pilote sont très très symptomatique
d'une certaine manière on peut
s'interroger sur l'opportunité qu'il y a
à recueillir les confidences d'un
commandant de bord qui parle sous la
contrainte d'un revolver cela pose un
véritable problème mais c'est un
obstacle difficilement contournable
parce que ce pilote dans son cockpit
c'est un homme qui donne une information
d'abord il rassure sur son sort
même s'il parle sous la contrainte il
parle il délivre un message donc donc
pour nous c'est un choix très difficile
et en réalité et lorsqu'il ya une
information aussi discutable soit elle
nous devons la des livres mais les
musulmans chiites comme les afghans
savent bien aussi qu'ils apportent des
messages des informations et que de ce
fait nous serons obligés de les passer
absolument et nous devons en être tout à
fait conscient merci jacques à bouchard
[Musique]